hi everyone this is the fourth of my
2021 recordings
answering questions submitted to and
voted
on on the alternative social media
platform
think spot we're also releasing these
answers on thinkspot a few days prior to
the release
on youtube you can get an advanced view
of the q and a's there if you so wish
at the thinkspot.com front page
the thinkspot platform is still in beta
so your attention and consideration
to this new venture would be much
appreciated
what's the most effective way of
overcoming self-deception
well that's a complicated
problem but i suppose there's some
relatively simple
answers to it i mean
i guess the reason i i commented on it
being complicated is that
you can ask a question like that in a
very short period of time
and that sort of implies that there's
an equally short answer in some sense
but
the problem of self-deception is
extremely thorny
and it's tangled up with the issue of
ignorance as well right how do you know
when you just don't know something and
how do you know when you're being
willfully blind and how do you know when
you're outright lying
all of those things are especially to
yourself all of those things are very
complicated
so to some degree the answer is
well you have to develop a philosophy
of life that's detailed
that contains within it an assessment
of your thoughts about the relationship
between
truth and deceit so for example
do you believe that it's okay to lie is
it okay to deceive other people to get
what you want
are there occasions when it's okay to
deceive other people if that helps them
get what they want
so that would be an
instance for example of what people
perhaps call white lies right lies that
are
designed to be of benefit are they
appropriate
do you feel that it's okay to deceive
yourself or
or other people in the pursuit of things
that you believe are valuable
and none of those are trivial questions
and and they can't be
answered with trivial answers so to some
degree you need
a moral philosophy that privileges the
truth above all else if you wish to
cease
engaging in self-deception and then you
might ask well how would you develop
such a philosophy and
some of that might be well reading about
moral philosophy reading literature
because it often deals with questions of
good and evil and deception thinking
about it
writing about it reading about it i said
that
um
and and also contemplating how central
an issue this is
for your life how important is this and
and why is it important if it's
important have you
lied and got into trouble do you believe
that
you can lie and get away with it if you
don't believe that you can get away with
it you still engage
in it if so why all right so let's leave
the complexity behind though but
but that's a necessary part of the
answer
how do you stop deceiving yourself
assuming that you want to stop doing so
well i don't believe that you can tell
unerringly when you're telling the truth
i think that some of the time when you
lie
outright you know
and so what i would recommend and have
recommended in my writings
in my books especially in
12 rules for life the first of my last
two books
said tell the truth or at least don't
lie and i added that
codicil to the phrase tell the truth
because
it became evident to me when i was
writing that
you know i don't know the truth
certainly not in its fullness
and so i can't say to someone tell the
truth
but i can say if you believe that the
truth is valuable and
if you believe that living your life
according to the dictates of the truth
is for the best for you and
and everyone else let's say
then you could at least stop lying
and then i would say
that as you pay attention to what you
say
so that you're attending to your
deceptive statements and trying to stop
making them
some of them maybe you know outright
they're not true some of them make you
feel uneasy and weak that would be a
less
uh evident criteria of falsehood but
still a
a reasonable one you stop
doing that and then your eye for such
things or your ear for such things or
your
embodied capacity to evaluate such
things develops just as everything
develops with
practice and your intent which is to
maintain truth in your speech becomes
sharper
and more focused across time and perhaps
you get
as you eliminate the obvious untruths
you get better and better at
detecting the more subtle untruths and
better and better and better and better
at avoiding
being entangled with those as well
so the first issue i guess is the
decision that
it's best to live in truth
and then you have to decide how far
you're willing to take that
if that becomes an absolute for example
or if it's a
you know an important guideline but
you know perhaps to be superseded by
other things
you have to sort that out for yourself
once having established that then
i believe that you decide
and practice not lying
and then possibly if you're fortunate
that the world smiles on you
you'll engage in less self-deception
i guess the last thing i would add to
that is that there's another form of
self-deception that i wrote about in
my the second of my last two books so
the last one beyond order
there's a chapter in there called don't
hide things in the fog
that really deals with self-deception
too so you might say well there's one
form of self-deception that occurs when
you say something that you know not to
be true and pretend even to yourself
that it's true
or even act as if it's true or base
other statements or actions
on it as if it's true but there's a more
subtle form of self-deception which i
think is more pervasive which is
the unwillingness to look at or the
willingness to turn away
from evidence that you know would
undermine something that you want to
believe or make things
inconvenient for you you know i think
i got cliched example is
maybe someone runs a company and they
have a chief financial
officer and they know that person is not
exactly straight
but it's convenient not to look at the
books so
maybe when they're around that person
they feel guilty and
and uncomfortable and that's a sign that
you know something's rotten in the state
of denmark so to speak
but then the self-deceptive act is to
not look
where you know you should look and
you know that's the sort of thing that
people refer to when they talk about the
elephant under the carpet or the
skeleton in the closet
and sometimes to mix metaphors terribly
it's better to let sleeping dogs lie but
often you know if you have the sense
that there's something more to the story
it's painful and difficult to delve into
it
but to not do so which is the easy route
is a form of of self-deception a very
common self-deception
and i don't think my experience as a
clinician
and my personal experience as well is
that
when you have a sense that something's
up and you fail to act
you almost inevitably pay a much higher
price
for it at some point deferred into the
future
so you have to think that through for
yourself and ask yourself if you believe
that's true and if it is true unless you
want more trouble in the future then
perhaps you investigate when your
moral unease let's say
makes alerts you to the fact that
there's something to investigate
as a woman and this is completely
different topic
as a woman i have fantasies about bad
boys is this something i need to mature
out of or realize
in my sex life in different ways
well i can't say for sure because i
don't know anything about your sex life
and i don't know anything about the
fantasies i would say
however that you know it's not that easy
to
maintain sexual interest
on a continuously rewarding basis across
long spans of time say with the same
partner
now maybe it's not that easy to maintain
it period
you know as we age say
fantasy can can provide pointers to
overcome that proclivity for
the deterioration of sexual interest
i remember reading i think it was in
raymond carver
who i love whose works i love a
detective he wrote
the greatest of detective novels
uh private eye really
um no it was raymond chandler sorry
raymond
chandler he talked about
the beauty industry in the fashion
industry and the hundreds of millions of
dollars billions of dollars that people
spend on that
enhancing sexual interest and came to
the conclusion that it was all worth it
because it's difficult to do it's
difficult to pull beauty into sexuality
it's difficult for each of us to
maintain our attractiveness to other
people
it it's difficult under many
circumstances
to maintain being attracted
well so you have these fantasies and
that's
the part of you that has a proclivity
towards sexual gratification
bet your best bet and
so those are fantasies that you could
hypothetically talk about with your
partner
assuming that you have a partner that
you could talk to about such things and
maybe that would free
him or her up to talk about such things
with you
and maybe your partner might be more
interested in your fantasies and
helping you along with them than you
think
it also
now you also asked the question about
immaturity
i think i would look for the wheat
instead of throwing it all out as chaff
to begin with
um take your cues from your fantasies
now i'm assuming that
you know you do that in a relatively
intelligent way and that it doesn't hurt
you it doesn't hurt the other person and
that it's uh you know there's mutual
consent involved in all of those things
that a wise person would do but
i wouldn't throw the baby out with the
bathwater and the reason for that is
that
if you have fantasies about something
that you need
sexually say and those aren't
satisfied in your life they're not
realized in your life
then when the opportunity to realize
them comes up in the form of
the possibility of an affair let's say
or a betrayal
you're much more likely to be tempted in
that direction than you would be if you
had incorporated that
into a broader conception of what your
sex life might be
so you know
one way of maintaining satisfaction with
a monogamous partner is to vary what you
do with that partner
and if that variation is fueled
by your mutual sexual fantasies and then
those fantasies are gratified then
one source of motivation to look
elsewhere and potentially blow your
whole life up and
that of your partner as well while doing
so is ameliorated
so eric neumann
famous student of carl jung said
don't pretend to be better than you
are now he didn't mean don't
try to be a moral person don't try to
improve yourself or any of that he meant
don't lie about
what you are and what you want and
you know maybe you're ashamed of it well
maybe you should be
but maybe you shouldn't be and i think
assuming that those basic moral
preconditions that i
described earlier are met then
think about it as an elaborated sexual
game
and as something that you might play
in a sophisticated and aware manner with
a
willing and able partner
what did i teach my children about sex
is there a healthy middle ground
for them without being naively celibate
or damagingly promiscuous
and how did you communicate that
you know i didn't teach them my kids
much explicitly about sex
i actually don't remember
any conversations about sex per se
and i can't even really remember how
they found out about sex
i'm certain that they knew the basic
mechanics
plenty early enough
so it wasn't like it was a taboo subject
it just
in some sense never seemed necessary
now that doesn't mean that there wasn't
any instruction about
sex in our household i mean
the kids watched i mean what do you
teach
children about sex while you teach them
how to be good people
in the broadest possible sense and so
one element of that would be
don't casually use
and hurt other people and you act that
out as a parent
to the degree that you're capable and
your children observe that
they also observe how you treat
your wife or husband how they're
observing that all the time you can be
sure of that and then they also observe
how you treat
your son and your daughter and how you
differentially treat them as well and so
they're learning
about sex in the broader context of
human relationships
all the time and most of that's implicit
and so you know my
wife and i my wife tammy and i have a
strong
monogamous relationship um
that's what we explicitly committed to
and
what we both implicitly desire and
physical affection and some of that
demonstrative
some of that the kids witnessed us
hugging or kissing that sort of thing
nothing more than that no but they
certainly weren't
strangers to the idea that we found each
other attractive and
and that we wanted to be with each other
without them
with some degree of frequency and all of
that is instructive to children
and but i think the most important
lesson
about the morality of sex was probably
taught to them
merely as a consequence of observing how
we treated each other
and and also by extension how we treated
them
i think that the expectation that they
dealt with sex wisely
was part of a broader expectation that
they dealt with
temptation wisely with drugs for example
i thought about this a lot because and
this has to do with your issue of
you know is there a reasonable middle
ground
healthy middle ground i knew from the
psychological literature that there was
a healthy middle ground with regard to
rule breaking in adolescence right so
you see pathology at
both ends of the normal distribution
there's kids who break rules all the
time the antisocial types and
and they you know they're at risk for
being arrested and for long-term
criminal behavior they're at higher risk
for that sort they've been getting in
trouble at school getting in trouble
with the police as teenagers all of that
that's obvious right but then on the
other end of the distribution there are
kids who never break
any rules and you might think well
that's optimal you know
they don't break laws they never
shoplift and this is not a pro
shoplifting
uh message by the way but you know
healthy teenagers
push the limits they break some rules
the ones who
never do that sort of thing tend to have
a
proclivity towards internalizing
disorders that's what they're called
externalizing disorders are disorders of
acting out and
internalizing disorders are more like
depression and anxiety
so they tend to be over-inhibited and
over-emotional in a negative sense and
suffer more from depression and anxiety
because they're
terrified and that's partly why they
don't break any rules they're too afraid
and
and that has a detrimental long term
consequence for them so you know you
you don't want your children to be
unable to take risks because they're
terrified of doing
something wrong with breaking the rule
and they need to test limits
with drugs i told them
i better not ever be able to tell that
you've been
using something because
if i can tell then you can't handle it
and that means that you're not doing it
appropriately and
that was about the best i could muster
because it was complicated
you know i mean i knew that they were
going to smoke pot they went to
alternative schools that was a given
it's like well what's the rule exactly
don't do drugs well
you know they probably observed tammy
alright taking the odd puff
so and maybe having the odd drink and so
you know that rule wasn't abided by
rigidly by either of us that we
certainly didn't abuse anything
um
or if we did it was only on very special
occasions
so i thought a lot about what the rule
is and the rule is don't be an idiot
you know if you're gonna smoke pot
don't smoke so much that you're drooling
and everyone can tell you're
stoned from two blocks away
because that's humiliating to you and to
the observer as well it's
degrading so and
sex is like that too it's like who's got
the upper hand you or this
or the sex so and i think the kids just
knew that and you know i watched their
relationships they had
serial monogamous relationships in team
as teenagers which is par for the course
and
by and large they handled them
as well as you could expect two
reasonable people who were teenagers to
handle them
and i generally like their choice of
partner thank god although not always
and that was awful when that was the
case but it didn't happen that
frequently
so i didn't have to teach them
explicitly what they had already been
taught implicitly
and you probably can't teach things
explicit
people things explicitly if they haven't
had the groundwork laid for that
teaching
implicitly so
as it pertains to beauty standards
do you think that progressive social
pressure
can overcome what appears to be our
ingrained attraction to
for example physical markers for
biological health okay so this
questionnaire is
influenced by hypothetically by
literature indicating that we value such
things
as physical markers of fecundity
which is fertility and that's associated
with health well of course we'd value
that because
obviously assuming that you
give some credence to evolutionary
theory
a species that didn't find
markers for reproductive success
attractive
wouldn't last very long so it's in some
sense self-evident well what are some of
those markers
symmetry in face and body
in gait uh more symmetrical people are
more attractive
they're and they are healthier because
illnesses of various sort during the
develop development
produce asymmetries and so and
that preference for symmetry is marked
in many species
uh even butterflies for example are
vastly more attracted towards perfectly
symmetrical mates
physical strength in men particularly so
shoulder width shoulder-to-width ratio
in men
is another marker height
voice depth
there's some markers associated with
testosterone like
jaw width in men
in women like for men women men find
younger women more attractive
all things considered that's younger
women who've
reached puberty obviously in the vast
majority of cases and
in the vast in the in the reasonable
case let's say
um now
and i think that attempts to
push back too hard against that kind of
proclivity
are ill-advised all things considered
but you know i would modify that to some
degree because
one of the things that we have decided
in the last
few generations let's say is that
people should be older than
mere post-pubescence before their
reasonable targets of sexual seduction
now if you go back 100 years ago or
farther than that it wasn't particularly
uncommon
for girls who are very young by today's
standards to be
engaged or married or involved in
the kind of relationship that might lead
to those two
states 14 13 15.
um now girls of that age frequently date
in our society but
we've decided that sexual activity
especially if there's an age gap of any
substantive
degree uh well can is
statutory rape so
progressive social
pressure so to speak has produced
it might not be precisely a decrement in
the perceived attractiveness
but it's definitely produced a change in
behavior
and expectation and so you know we have
biological proclivities but we're also
an
extraordinarily malleable species and
you can see too that different cultures
specialize in different markers of
beauty
and some of those specialized markers of
beauty don't translate well from one
culture to another
so there's a central human tendency
associated with perceived
attractiveness but any of the dimensions
of variability that compose that central
tendency
can be altered substantially by social
pressure and social expectation
so it's complicated like any issue of
nature and nurture
my basic sense is is that you leave
people the hell alone with regard to
what they find attractive
and you know we hear stories that
there's a corporate construction of
beauty that's
fed to us and i think that's
fundamentally rubbish in some sense
because
corporations who use sex to sell
are much more likely to succeed if they
merely
provide um
gratification for the instincts that are
already there rather than trying to
create them out of nothing for their own
purposes
now you might say despite that that
the fact that stereotyped
portrayals of beauty are put forward to
us by
powerful media organizations every day
intensifies our focus on those
attributes and that might be true
but that's not the same argument as
trying to make the case that you know
that that's a construction and nothing
else and
i think the evidence for that is weak to
the point of non-existence
despite the variability that i described
so yes i think that progressive social
pressure can overcome
certain ingrained attractions
um and we've deemed that
necessary in many cases i mean
it's also the case at least we've we've
stopped
action on those attractions to a great
degree and the same thing happens when
you get
involved in a monogamous relationship
and does i
decide to forsake all others
you might again argue that well the
attraction to others isn't ameliorated
but i would say it is to some degree
partly because people who are in a
committed relationship
just don't allow themselves to go there
right so
they might note attraction but they
don't dwell on it and they don't
pursue it and so that is some
amelioration of the attraction by
social pressure not necessarily
progressive
so i'm worried i will never find love
what do i do well the first thing i
would say that you should do is
understand that you are not alone in
that worry
a more common worry could hardly be
identified so
and if you find love then you'll
probably worry about whether you'll keep
it or whether or not that's the right
love for you so
i guess part of the answer is you act in
spite of your worry
and that's actually the best treatment
for your worry
you know you might be so concerned that
you're unwilling to
put yourself out there and face
rejection
and i would say the best way to overcome
fear of rejection is to put yourself in
a situation where you're
where you get rejected and have that
happen to the point where you're
not devastated by it i'm not saying
that's easy
and hopefully that will those attempts
will also be
punctuated by some success so i would
say
despite your worry get out there you
know
ask someone for his or her phone number
uh put up a profile on a dating site or
at least create a profile maybe you can
wait a week or two to post it but put
some effort into it and get a nice
photograph taken
um i think and then you could also ask
yourself are you worried about being
alone
for the rest of your life too and that's
a good thing to worry about so i
you might say well that's the same as
worried being worried i'll never find
love but
if you let that stop you then there's
this alternative danger
isn't there that you'll just be alone so
accept the worry as part of
the likely
content of human existence
and do what you can to make yourself
attractive
to the people that you wish to be
attracted to you
and then put yourself out there and
the probability is quite high that
you'll find someone who
will love you about as much as you love
them and maybe you'll
and maybe that'll be good enough
i'm having a hard time disciplining
myself i particularly struggle to
establish a schedule
how did you make a schedule so that many
of your highest goals could be attained
i know that you've talked about making a
schedule on many occasions but i would
like to look
inside your schedule from the time that
you think was your prime
well
some people find it harder than other
people to make a schedule you know one
thing you might
consider doing is doing the personality
test at understandmyself.com and
seeing what you're like you know maybe
you're
particularly low in conscientiousness in
which case making a schedule and
sticking to a routine an orderly routine
is going to be quite difficult for you
but that'll at least help you understand
perhaps at least some of the problems
maybe you're high in negative emotion or
neuroticism and so you worry too much
about making a schedule that just stops
you from doing it
um i would say
well first thing to do is
there's two things you could do first of
all the first thing you might want to do
is figure out
why you want to make a schedule to begin
with so you talked about goals well what
is it that you want to accomplish
the future authoring program at self
authoring.com another one of our
websites
helps people make a detailed plan for
the future
and so you can't really have a schedule
without
having a plan because the activities you
schedule
should be intelligently related to
goals you wish to achieve that are
important to you and so you need to have
goals that you wish to achieve that are
important to you and you have to know
what they are
and that's complicated right that's like
a plan for your life so it's very
difficult and so that's why we produce
this exercise which
helps step you through the process of
deciding
what you want and need
there's a present authoring program
there too that helps you identify your
virtues and your faults and
part of your plan can involve
capitalizing on those virtues and
rectifying those faults and so that can
be an interesting addition to this
process but
in any case you have to figure out what
you want
and then you have to figure out how to
decompose what you want into
actionable steps right and those would
be the sorts of things that you could
put into schedule
now that would mean that your schedule
would hypothetically consist of things
that you
maybe you don't exactly want to do
although that would be good but at least
you understand the importance of doing
and are therefore somewhat motivated to
do
and then you need to break those steps
down
into small enough increments that you're
highly likely to undertake them
you know so for example this is a
trivial example maybe you have to
do a report on a given topic for school
and you're not very good at that well
you know
maybe you could go to the library one
day and just check out the library
that might be enough and then maybe you
could go to the library and
take out a book and then maybe you could
open the book
and look through it those would be on
different days and then maybe you could
sit down and read the first
page of the book and if you can't do
that then the first paragraph
you know you have to negotiate with
yourself and figure out what
the largest step
you would take towards your goal is that
you would
take and if you don't do it then you
make the steps smaller and smaller until
you find something that you would do
you the next thing you need to do
potentially is to familiarize yourself
with a scheduler like google calendar
so the first thing to do is open it
and then maybe to figure out how to put
in a
task and then a repeating task and it
might be a pretty simple one
to begin with it's like well why don't
you list
waking up and specify a time or going to
bed and specifying a time an approximate
time anyways or
put in the schedule when you eat
and those are things you do every day
and so that's something you're pretty
likely to do
and so that's a success for you and then
well then you can
start by putting in something small
maybe you need to read maybe you need to
exercise maybe you need to
uh have a social event with people
um maybe you need to watch tv a movie
whatever
it doesn't matter what it is hopefully
it's something you want to do
put it in the schedule and you could
start by scheduling the things that you
would like to do so you can imagine well
i like going out to movies i like going
to the mall i like hanging around with
my friends i like watching tv
i like reading a book i like listening
to music
well then schedule those things
and so then you think well that means
i'm forcing myself to do them it's not
that it's that now you're
you're allowing yourself time
to do them right so the schedule becomes
a means of you getting what you want
instead of
an external jailer who punishes you
every time you deviate from
requirement so you have to make friends
with the schedule and the
schedule has to be your friend your ally
i shouldn't use that word but
you know what i mean it should work for
you and not against you it's not
you're not generating an external tyrant
you know you are generating something
that you could be
held to you know and that's be
responsible too and that's not
necessarily a bad thing it can be
somewhat burdensome but it's not
necessarily a bad thing but
generally you should approach it as if
this is something that
will help you get what you want
and it's also
a pretty good way of controlling anxiety
you know because
one of the most common sources of
anxiety is just not knowing what to do
and people often think about that as
boredom and and it is bored to some
degree it can be but
it can also be very anxiety provoking
it's like well
what should i do i don't know what to do
well
i have to do something there's all these
things i could do and
i don't want to make that decision every
hour so a schedule
that you designed that you like can be
an incredible relief
and one thing we do know is that
conscientious people
tend to be lower in negative emotion
and it looks like that's a causal
consequence is that orderly people for
example because they're
they order their environment and make it
more predictable
then they're less likely to be anxious
because we're often made anxious by what
is unpredictable
so generating a view of your life
that consists of valued goals that you
want to
attain and then steps by which those
might be attained and the future
authoring program helps you figure all
that out
well then you can ally that with a
schedule
and then you know not only do you know
what you're doing you know that what
you're doing is moving you towards
something you want and that's rewarding
and having your time structured like
that and and attaining those goals
is pleasurable and anxiety reducing
so you know that's pretty good deal all
things considered and you can start
stupid and slow like i said just
throw some things in that you're pretty
high pretty likely to do
and fill in the schedule with broad
strokes and then as you get
familiar with it and comfortable with it
and maybe even happy with it
you can fill in the details and start to
use it in a more sophisticated way
but everyone i know who's accomplished
almost everyone i know who's
accomplished does structure their time
explicitly
in that manner they've learned to do
that over the years now
not everyone does that really really
entrepreneurial people might have a
harder time with it
especially if they're low in
conscientiousness but
um and then with regard to the
personality test you know maybe you do
personality tests
the personality test i mentioned say and
you find out that you're
agreeable but low in conscientiousness
well so it's going to be harder for you
to stick to a schedule but
you do like to please other people so
that's one of the things that you could
schedule you'd be highly likely to do
that if you're extroverted you could
schedule time
you know socializing with people if
you're introverted you could schedule
time
by yourself walking in nature for
example or
doing whatever else it is that you might
want to do by yourself
if you're open you could schedule in
creative time and then
you'd be motivated to do those things so
you have a you're having a hard time
disciplining yourself that's
that's par for the course you know i
mean
like i said really conscientious people
are more
inclined in that direction but it's hard
to discipline yourself
in relationship to a goal you know it's
like it's
it's like training a cart horse to pull
a cart it's it's difficult
and so start with little things and
maybe little things that you want to do
and then you can proceed to harder
things that you don't
want to do so much you know further
extrinsic or intrinsic
utility but you have to do them because
they're related to something important
you'll get disciplined across time if
you do that and
incremental improvement that's sustained
is extremely powerful
from the perspective of transformation
how do i know if i'm a good or a bad
person
i struggle with viewing myself as a good
human being who deserves good things in
return
even though i try my best to be decent
and add light into this world in a
multitude of ways
what are some steps to take in order to
become better than the person i was in
the past
okay well there's a question that you
didn't answer that's a logical
consequence
of the question you did answer you said
you struggle with viewing yourself as a
good human who deserves good things in
return
so now you have two problems one is well
how can you be a better person
but the other problem is well how do you
treat yourself
as the good person you already are he
said you have trouble with that so the
other question might be how do i treat
myself
how do i reward myself for being good or
how do i value the fact that i am good
at least some of the time
okay you struggle with knowing whether
you're a good or a bad person well
you're probably good
and a bad person right just like
everybody else and so
the first thing to understand is that
that's
part and parcel of being human that
we're insufficient embodiments of
our own ideals and that's always the
case and even if we do progress
our ideal becomes more sophisticated and
so we still exist in a
relationship of judgment with our
ideal and and to some degree
that's permanent it's just part of the
condition of being human
having said that just like it's
reasonable to in
to assume someone's innocence before
and having their guilt proved rather
than the other way around
it's useful for you to reward yourself
for being good
on those occasions that you were good
and so
that'll also help you accept yourself
more
completely as a good person to the
degree that you are so
you know when you do something good you
might
try to make it a habit of noting that
maybe telling someone about it or at
least telling yourself about it and
maybe rewarding yourself in some way for
it at least by the recognition
and that then you'll come to accept
yourself as a good person
more easily right and you imagine if if
you had a child around you and
you were trying to reward them for being
a good person and
also encourage them to be good you would
notice when they've done something good
and tell them you know and
and and make a bit of an issue out of it
and being specific about it really helps
you know i noticed
that you when you cut up that apple
you gave a little more than half to your
sister and you didn't have to do that
that shows you're paying attention and
that's very powerful and you can do that
with yourself
too you know you notice when you did
what you were supposed to that day or
when you did something kind for someone
else or when you did something
creative that that worked out or at
least when you attempted to do that you
know
or when you managed to control
a very tempting bad habit
it's very hard to learn to reward
yourself properly for proper
action but it's very much worth doing
and it will spill into your
relationships with other people
and so you treat yourself like
someone you're trying to do the best for
it
it's hard to do that because you're
acutely aware of your own faults let's
say but
you don't want to dispense with your
virtues what are some steps to take in
order to become better than the person i
was in the past
well i talked earlier today about the
future authoring program i'm going to
return to that i mean we built that for
a reason
you need to lay out a vision of yourself
as an ideal like who do you want to be
five years from now what do you want
your life to be like across the most
important dimensions of your life
we need a vision of that first of all
something to aim at you know
what would you like your family
relationships to be like if they were
ideal
what would your intimate relationship be
like if it was better
what would your job be like or your
career
how might you take care of yourself
mentally and physically
how do you regulate your
your proclivity towards harmful
temptations
how do you make intelligent use of your
of the time that you have for yourself
how do you continually educate yourself
how do you
illuminate yourself philosophically and
spiritually
you need a vision for that and a plan
and then you have to decompose that into
steps that'll lead you in that direction
and
that's how you incrementally move
towards being a better person and maybe
as you do that you have to revise your
ideal version of yourself because of
something you learned but that's okay
that's part and parcel of the process
so because you're not going to specify
the ideal with 100
accuracy the first time you
you specify it i'm 40 but i feel like a
child
watching everyone around me get older
and die so i'm homesick for the past
instead of accepting the terrifying
present
how can i stop mourning the past well
i grouped the last three questions
together including this one because they
all
allowed me to talk reasonably about
these programs the self-authoring
program has a past
authoring component that helps people
write out an autobiography now you're
suffering from what freud described as
reminiscences of the past you're
possessed by reminiscences they won't
get out of your mind and what that means
to me
is well it's one of two things one is
that
there's things in your past that you
need to
understand more deeply and that's why
they're still calling to you
and there are things in your past that
you had perhaps
that you need to have in the present and
the future and so
you could do the past authoring program
and write out your past
it it asks you to detail the most
emotionally significant events that
occurred
during different epochs or stages of
your life so you have to break your life
into a number of stages i think we
recommended six but you can break it
into as many as you want or as few
and then to deal out detail out the
significant positive and negative
occurrences you know that stand out in
your memory from those times and that'll
kind of help put the past to rest but it
also might highlight for you what it is
that you're nostalgic
for and then that can help you figure
out what to aim for in the future and so
you know it sounds like you're rather
hopeless about the present and by
implication the future and and maybe
that's because
you don't have a richly enough developed
conception of what it could be
so you could go back to your past and
find out what it is that you
wanted and had and then you need to make
a plan
for how you might obtain that in the
future um
now it's a bit more complicated than
that because you talked about death you
know and
and so you may be longing in some sense
for a return to
in a state of blissful ignorance where
you weren't concerned about
mortality and you know
the only real medic medication for that
i think that's real is to live as
worthwhile a life as you can as full of
life so you don't have regrets
i'm not sure that so much that people
are afraid of death there there may be
afraid of not
living enough and maybe if you lived
enough
you could let it go when it was time i i
think there's some truth in that
and so if you're overly afraid of death
it may be because you have a lot of
unlived life in you and
you could go back to the past and you
can find out what you
needed and perhaps had then and then you
can strive to attain that in the present
and the future
and those exercises could at least in
principle
help you with that so
what are you missing right what are you
missing that the past
had for you and maybe you write that
down like well i had this it was really
important to me and i
you know i had a loving relationship
with
someone and i don't have that now i i
had
the security of a comfortable home life
and i don't have that now it's well
those are things that
now become ambitions right because a
lack is
an ambition and a lack are mirror images
of one another
so if you can identify what you lack you
can derive an ambition from that
and you might say well that's impossible
it's like well you decompose it into
small steps
and that's complicated but so
life is complicated so there's no way
around that
what's your advice to someone who took
your understand myself
test and scored zero on agreeableness
but still recognizes the need to
collaborate with many people
well that's an interesting question zero
is pretty low
um the best personality predictor of
imprisonment conduct behavior
anti-social personality
criminality is low agreeableness now
it's not a very powerful predictor
uh at least as it's measured with
self-report questionnaires
but it's the most powerful predictor and
so if you're low in agreeableness you
will have the proclivity
to be less empathetic and sensitive to
other people
than they might like and you might also
be harsh and stubborn and
i mean there's advantages right you'll
tell the truth more likely
because you're not so concerned about
upsetting people you're
likely more difficult to stop um
and there's some utility in that once
you're set on your pathway
but it's reasonable for you to take a
good look at that because
it could easily cause you and other
people a fair bit of trouble
now i don't know the rest of your
personality configuration so
you know if you're conscientious but low
in agreeableness
well then you'll be able to keep and
maintain
contractual obligations the sense of
duty which isn't the same as the
empathic sense that indicated by
agreeableness the sense of duty will
keep you to your word so if you're high
in conscientiousness well
then you can rely more on contractual
obligation like what's the deal here
what's my end of the deal what do i have
to do to uphold that
it has to be more explicit rather than
implicit because
you're not going to be a good gauge of
other people's emotional state and you
said yourself
personally i feel almost zero regard for
the emotions of those around me
yet i can't avoid them and complete what
i need to do at the same time okay so
you have a strategic problem as well
so um
you also might practice consciously
practice
doing things for other people and you'd
have to do that strategically
there is some evidence i don't remember
where i ran across this that
doing so is a facilitator of mental
health
and so you might have to learn to be act
agreeable
more explicitly when you're
undertaking something with someone you
may have to learn to ask yourself
explicitly
what's in it for them right why is this
an
equitable arrangement and and if you're
conscientious that's going to be an
easier thing to
to understand so
well what can you do about being so low
in agreeableness well
you can capitalize on your other
personality traits you know maybe you're
high in openness and so
what you can offer to other people is
the opportunity to
collaborate with you in a creative
endeavor and
they might leap at that opportunity
maybe you're extroverted now extroverted
disagreeable people tend to be
narcissistic so that's that's a rough
one
um because if you're extroverted and
disagreeable well then
your narcissism is gonna be problematic
and that's especially true if you're low
in conscientiousness because then you
won't be able to keep verbal
contracts either so
um but if you're extroverted let's say
well you do have
the option of being entertaining and
enthusiastic and that's something you
have to offer other people
so you have to look at your entire
personality constellation and figure out
what
you need to rely on to rectify
those areas where you're
you know where you deviate substantially
from the norm
you may also need to find someone in
your life who is agreeable assuming they
can stand you
um they might be attracted to you just
out of perverseness but
and and ask for their opinion
because their superior empathic sense
let's say
might lay them open to um exploitation
that's the downside of high
agreeableness by the way
uh but they're going to be much more
attuned to the social niceties of a
given situation and so
you might need to ally yourself with
someone who's clearly more empathic and
and you know control your tendency to
take advantage of them if you can
so um and then the last thing i said
well
practice you know doing things for other
people
you might have to do it coldly and
calculatingly at least to begin with
because
you don't have that easy empathic sense
but
that doesn't mean it has to be false you
know
it's it depends on what it's in service
of and if it's in service of
rectifying and maintaining your
relationships with other people then
that's an admirable goal
even if it's a cold cognitive goal
rather than a warm and health
heartfelt goal and so it's certainly
better than the alternative which is
to not do it at all so you know maybe
you have to
do something altruistic once a week
or something like that as part of your
attempt to broaden the scope of your
personality
you know and then maybe you could have
the advantages of being disagreeable
which means
for example that you're no pushover and
that you know you'll pursue your own
agenda that you'll strive to win and
and so forth you could have the
advantages of that and
some of the advantages of being someone
whose empathy makes them
easier to get along with and to
collaborate with other people
i'm 25. i had a drug problem
when i was younger in my late teens and
early 20s
i stole money on multiple occasions i
don't even know who some of those people
i stole from
are and can't repay them however
even in the instances where i could
apologize or repay i feel completely
unable to
i'm too ashamed this bothers me
all the time i can't sleep or do
anything
i really hate myself i think that i'm a
rotten person
and don't know how to handle it do you
have any advice for this
well if i was your therapist i would say
tell me about every single occasion that
you remember where this happened
now you can't tell me because i'm not
there but you could write it down
and that would help it
and and maybe you could write down why
you did it
and maybe you could do that with a bit
of compassion
you know i mean obviously your behavior
was sufficiently reprehensible to be
plaguing your conscience but
at least you have a conscience that's
something and so
and people make mistakes especially when
they're young
especially when they're added by drug
use let's say
that's there's plenty of occasion there
for
misbehavior that's for sure
and it's pretty common
in any case you're plagued by this so
there is
the past has still got its tentacles
around you well
write it down write down every episode
every time you worry about something
like that write it down and get a list
that's your symptoms then you know
the idea of approaching one of these
people and apologizing and
offering to repay them that's a pretty
good idea
maybe you could list all the people that
you stole from
who you could do that with and then
rank order them in order of difficulty
and then
think about how you would approach the
least difficult of all those people
and what you'd say and maybe you have to
write that out
now i'm not saying you have to do it but
you could do that to begin with and then
you could decide whether or not you
could do it and if you could do it with
the easiest person
and then you could see how that goes
maybe that actually helps
and then if if you can't do that
maybe there are some other means of
clearing your conscience
so when you write all this down
write down how much you took
and then maybe your goal could be
you donate twice that amount
to a charity like to so you have to
research charity and find one that you
think is really valuable you know where
it would do some good
and so you know you don't have to pay it
all back at once but maybe you could pay
once a month or whatever i don't know
what your budget is
maybe twice a month maybe once every
three months whatever you could afford
and so then you've
atoned for your sin let's say
and you've transformed something bad
that the people who experienced have
probably already forgotten about i mean
unless you were stealing huge amounts of
money and destroyed their lives
they've probably moved on and so
you could transform your
nefarious actions into something that
was good
now maybe a donation to charity you know
wouldn't do it for you
you could try it once and see if that
helps you know pay off one of your
existential debts and and see if that
helps
it's a negotiation with yourself and so
then i guess i would also ask um
are you more broadly depressed and
anxious
you know what i mean so are you fixating
on this
in a manner that's truly
counterproductive
that's reflective of a deeper issue with
depression or anxiety
and you'd know that for example if you
know well you said you can't sleep
or do anything you really hate yourself
that's signs of
generalization beyond the confines of
these misdeeds and so
if that's the case then perhaps even if
you did
atone for what you had done other
preoccupations with
previous instances of
unacceptable behavior would start to
plague you to the same degree
that's a more complex problem and if
that's the case then
well your best bet then is to find a
competent
mental health professional and have
your circumstance evaluated
and you know if you're really torturing
yourself to death about this despite the
fact that you've
apparently ceased your drug abuse
well maybe there's something else
fueling it and you may need to
investigate that
so that's about all i can think of
along those lines why do we need to
contemplate our own malevolence
what if you get stuck in it how do you
move forward after becoming aware of it
especially if you've actually done
something bad
i'm not speaking of criminal behavior
well
i think the reason that we need to
contemplate our own malevolence is so
that
we don't
i think it's a human propensity
a profoundly deep human propensity to
see the world in terms of good and evil
shades of good and evil but even
absolutes of good and evil
and we understand that malevolence
exists that
now and then people act
to hurt others and although
apologists exclaimed that
that's generally motivated by the desire
for some good
i'm not convinced uh there's a certain
pleasure
in vengeful harm
and we all
feel the desire to be vengeful
merely as a consequence of the in some
sense
the perceived central unfairness of
existence itself
and the undeserved suffering that seems
to accompany it
it's easy to become frustrated by that
and embittered by that and to lash out
and to hurt
and so that's malevolence well
and it's a very destructive force now
and we don't
think well of it and so
if you identify malevolence
somewhere else than within
you can become powerfully motivated to
take corrective action against the
perceived source of malevolence
so i see that for example when critics
of
our social structures insist that the
fundamental
motivating factor that organizes those
structures is
the arbitrary expression of undeserved
power
or invalid power privileged power let's
say well
yes to some degree because every
structure has its element of corruption
none of us are perfect and
neither are institutions but the danger
of that view is that
once you've identified the locale of
malevolence and it's not you
well then you're a moral actor and can
do no wrong in your pursuit of the
wrongdoer
and that's very very dangerous it's not
that easy to identify the wrong doer
especially when you're talking about
social institutions and
some appreciation of your own
malevolence
might stop you from being so vicious in
your pursuit of
the perceived wrongdoers who are
who aren't you and
you know that one of the terrible
attributes of utopian totalitarian
societies
is their proclivity to localize
malevolence in some group
and then their unbridled pursuit of
destruction
in relationship in relationship to that
group
and all the atrocities that go along
with that as a consequence of that
attribution of malevolence
and so it's a tenet of the
judeo-christian
ethic that the adversary is best
confronted within
and now you know you object to that for
good reasons like do you really want to
do that do you really want to see
yourself as
a perpetrator rather than a victim or a
hero
and the answer to that is well no it's
devastating it can be devastating
but you know it says it's been said that
the fear of god is the beginning of
wisdom and
i think that that fear of god so to
speak is allied with
this apprehension of internal
malevolence
i don't think that you can be motivated
to be good i don't think you can be
serious about your attempts to be good
unless you have some real sense of
just how far off track you can
get or have got and how malevolent you
have been or could be in your actions
you just don't take yourself seriously
enough until you see the devil within
and when you see that well it can be
traumatizing and you're objecting to
that what if you get stuck in that
and it's no wonder people don't want to
contemplate it but
it's not easy for me to see how you can
go through
all the difficult gyrations necessary to
put your moral house in order if you
don't view yourselves
as akin to the perpetrator in very many
important senses
so and you take that on to yourself and
try to rectify that within yourself and
so
i guess you contemplate your own
malevolence so that you don't
unconsciously project
malevolence onto others and and assume
your own
you know
assume your own moral rectitude now you
know this might contradict what i said
about innocent before
proven guilty and those are difficult
things to reconcile you know but
i guess that's why this the
idea of original sin emerged at least in
part
you know it's not necessarily that any
of us are
specifically guilty of something
and that's the legal issue and and maybe
that's the issue
with regards to your treatment of others
when you're formally accused of a crime
the proper presumption is innocence
that doesn't mean the proclivity isn't
there
so i know those things are hard to sort
out and and maybe my explanation doesn't
differentiate them you know
as wisely as they might be
differentiated but
you can be sorely tempted
toward something as an indicator of your
malevolence without being
guilty of acting that out and you have
to deal with
the fact of sore temptation as well as
the fact that
you're innocent in that you didn't act
it out
so it's something like that
you have to localize malevolence
somewhere because you you tend to see it
as an existential constant right it's
it's it's something that exists in the
world that needs a locale
and the safest locale and the most
salutary locale i believe is
the identification of malevolence within
um it isn't obvious to me that that's
more traumatizing than
localizing it in the social structures
for example but
it might be
you spoke once about going into the deep
to save your father but i never knew my
father at all so who is it that i'm
saving
well i would say that you're saving
your relationship with the paternal
spirit
so the egyptians had a god
of the state that was osiris osiris
he was the old king and he was archaic
and willfully blind
especially to the machinations of his
evil brothers seth
and so the egyptians
represented their knowledge of social
structures
in a narrative and well the the social
structure
you know the culture is like an old king
whose best days are behind him and who
is
always in danger of being overthrown by
his evil brother
it's like very astute representation of
the state
well horus is the god of attention
he has he's the eye the famous egyptian
eye
of horus and he's the falcon who can see
and and so he pays attention and that
capacity to pay attention
as for the egyptians was what rescued
osiris from the depths of the underworld
when he was
overthrown by his malevolent brother
so who are you saving while you're
saving
osiris and that could be your father
insofar as the spirit of osiris
characterizes your father but if you
don't have a father that doesn't mean
that spirit isn't there so maybe what
you're doing is
rescuing your relationship with the
central animating tendency of
human civilization insofar as that's
paternal
or maybe you're rescuing your
relationship with god the father
that being an expression of that
animating principle
um it's complicated but that's
that's the gist of it so
you you repair your relationship with
the culture that gave
birth to you and that's the father in
the broadest
sense well not the broadest sense
because that would be god but
in a broader sense so
you repair your relationship with what's
common across
all men that might be another way of
thinking about it
does life have meaning without god can
life be meaningful without god and
without eternity
well
at the highest and most abstract levels
perhaps not
so i mean
life has proximal meanings right there's
the meaning
that you experience when you're engaged
in a piece of art
or when you're reading or when you're
engrossed in a movie or in a
conversation
there's the meaning that emerges
within your relationships with people
that you cherish
or are enthusiastic with there's
meanings of security
and predictability there's meanings of
duty and responsibility and active
engagement with your job and your career
there's meanings of aesthetic pleasure
now all of those
have their value and each of them has
their place
and you know maybe there's a hierarchy
of value there as well
so that some of those meanings are
deeper than others
and then you might say well what
characterized the deepest of all
meanings and it would be something like
relationship with the transcendent and
that would establish a relationship
between you
and what's always been conceptualized is
god which is
generally supposed to be something
ineffable right it's not definable but
you might think about it as
the central animating spirit of the age
or
the value around which all other values
are organized or
the wisdom of the ages or the creative
spirit that possesses you when you're
inspired
or what grips you with enthusiasm at a
sports event or
at a musical event all of those things
and
we need a relationship with that and
we find our deepest meaning in that
relationship and if we don't find it
i think if we don't find it in something
that's explicitly
religious then we tend to magnify
something of lesser value say something
political
into that to fill the void
so yes life has proximal meanings
without god without eternity but
at the ultimate level something's
lacking
and it's the desire to fulfill that lack
that
and maybe the lock itself that's part
and parcel of the religious instinct
so you can kill god
but you can't that doesn't rectify the
hunger for god
and then that hunger seeks out
replacements
that's how it looks to me so
and then you know you you might also say
well does that mean you have to believe
in god and
i don't think of the proper answer to
that is that
you need to agree with a propositional
statement does god exist
yes like does this is this table there
yes it's not that kind of
relationship it's characterized in the
old testament as a struggle
so israel means those who struggle with
god
and you have to
participate in that struggle and you can
do that weirdly enough
as a believer as a non-believer maybe
sometimes more intensely as a
non-believer
the issue might be more paramount than
the issue of virtue and
and the issue of the ultimate
orientation
dr peterson as an art student i wonder
how to create a poetic piece
deeply storied and metaphoric without
becoming a piece of propaganda
i feel like trying too hard to create a
meaningful and poetic piece often
results in the creation of something
rife with bias and ideology
however letting my unconscious take full
control creates what seems like an empty
and uninteresting piece
is there a method to control that chaos
without corrupting its meaning while
still expressing it poetically
for the time being i decided to
concentrate on learning good technique
well the first thing i would say is that
is what you should be doing as a student
is you should be concentrating on
learning good technique because those
are the tools that you're going to have
to express your
creative intuition so that's a great
place to start and you said you're a
student so
well you're not a master you're a
student
so of course you're going to wonder how
to create a poetic piece without
becoming a prop piece of propaganda
you're going to be struggling without
your entire artistic career
you know and you might say well the more
tools you have at your disposal
the more opportunity you have to produce
something of value
and so great that it's a it's a it's the
right answer to the problem well then
trying too hard i think a lot of what
artists do is play and so
i remember watching this video of pablo
picasso
creating a painting on a piece of glass
so you could see
exactly what he was doing and he'd paint
and erase and paint in a race and paint
the race and
he was just playing and watching what
was happening constantly and
he was sort of seeing what would happen
but he was very disciplined i mean he
had all the tools that is at hand right
i mean he'd gone through his
apprenticeship and so master your craft
and play with what you're mastering and
those two will come together across time
and now and then you'll produce a poetic
piece deeply storied and metaphoric
that isn't a piece of propaganda and
then you'll have succeeded as an artist
at least in that instance and then maybe
you'll be able to do that over and over
so don't try so hard that's part of it
perhaps
that doesn't mean don't
discipline yourself with regard to
broadening your skill set that's really
a good idea but then
you have to bring the spirit of play
into that and the spirit of discovery
and trying too hard and then when you
say you're trying too hard
what are you trying too hard to do you
know that might be worth thinking about
too
are you trying too hard to produce a
high quality piece of art
well maybe that's not the right goal
maybe the right goal is something like
i'm going to play with these new skills
that i've developed and see what happens
i mean picasso for example there's an
online
archive of picasso's work and you know
when he was painting roosters
he painted hundreds of them i think
castle produced 60 000 paintings some
outrageous number of paintings and they
were by no means all masterpieces
um although perhaps that's cynical
there were plenty of masterpieces that's
for sure and
so i'm not saying this in a denigrating
fashion
you could see picasso approaching a
masterpiece
in his repeated attempts to represent
say something like a rooster and
represent it this way represent this way
i represent it this way producing
multitudes of variants
and then you know honing in on the
ultimate goal or being able to select
from all those variants the
optimal representation playing
playing hard playing in a disciplined
fashion playing with the tools that he
had
and so
and that's part of letting the
unconscious in right is to to let
the process of play take you where it's
going to go
and maybe you have to abandon the idea
of producing the finished piece of art
or at least you have to abandon the idea
of producing it
on that occasion because art is a
process of exploration
right as well and so confining that to
the production of a given entity to
brutally is going to impede the
manifestation of that spirit
is there a way we can reach people who
are controlled by ideology
if schools are bent on teaching crt and
other marxist-inspired doctrine how can
we turn the tide
is there a way we can reach people who
are controlled by ideology
yes um by
acting honorably and by telling a better
story
so that's the goal right you have to
tell a better story
or you have to act out a better story
and and telling it would also be helpful
you have to offer something more
attractive fundamentally
and that doesn't mean that there's no
room for criticism but
i think telling a better story is the
fundamental issue if schools are bent on
teaching critical race they're in other
marxist inspired doctrine
how could we turn the tide well i
offered some ideas about that
tell a better story it's not
self-evident that indoctrinating
students at school
is going to work that well i mean i
remember myself as a junior high school
student and my friends we were pretty
cynical about what we were being taught
especially if it was contaminated by
something that it
shouldn't have been contaminated by and
so it might be that
pushing all this has exactly the
opposite consequence
at least over the long run we'll see but
basically you have to tell a better
story and you have to get your arguments
in order
and so if you have kids well that's
tough one
you can discuss what they learned at
home you can encourage them
to use their judgment i told my kids
you don't have to follow stupid rules
but if you break them and you get caught
well you have to deal with that
but as far as i'm concerned you know if
you've thought it through and the rule
is stupid
then well you're free to oppose it as
long as you're willing to take the
consequences
so you can you can have intelligent
discussions with your kids especially
if you're interested and they're willing
to bring things up
and so and you can keep an eye on what
they're being taught and then maybe you
can object to the teacher and you can
object to the school board
best to do it in writing and i would
also recommend and encourage that
i've cleaned my room and feel called to
serve the greater community
what are some signs that you're ready to
go in the world and serve people
offer you opportunities
or you see opportunities and maybe those
are the same thing
if you're ready the
your readiness primes you
to be cognizant of the next steps
forward
and then if you put yourself together
other people are going to recognize that
and they're going to
put opportunities in front of you and so
then you can say yes
and the way you go that's how that works
out
so another sign well you said you feel
called to serve the greater community
okay so that's a sign
as well i mean assuming that it's not
mere expression of narcissism on your
part
you're ready for it so watch and look
and see if you see an opportunity that
inspires you or that someone offers to
you
even if it's lowly in that direction
right even if it's starting at the
bottom
starting at the bottom is fine you learn
that way you learn everything about what
you're doing by starting at the bottom
and
there's something to be said for that so
last question in your last q a you said
you decided to
take the vaccine my friends and i were
surprised by this is it safer than i
think
i don't know you know
why did i get the vaccine well
balance of risk i suppose um
i don't need covid
um i've had enough health trouble and i
had covid
so i had covet and i got the vaccine
because some blood markers indicated
that my immunity might not be what it
should be
was it the right thing to do how the
hell do i know i don't bloody well know
um i don't think the vaccine makers are
conspiratorial fundamentally or any more
than any other
organization um my wife
was very ill in recent years and is
somewhat immunocompromised so that
entered into it i
wanted to stop worrying about covid um
it seemed to me that the evidence that
case rates plummeted
after the vaccine was strong i've had
vaccines before and they don't seem to
have hurt me
i felt some obligation not to be a
carrier although i would say that
wasn't the prime issue i'm sick and
tired of the lockdown
and assume that if in canada we reach a
certain threshold of vaccinated people
that
it'll be done with and i'm ready for
that and willing to take some risk for
it
um but you know i have family members
who
don't want to take the vaccine and i can
certainly understand why and
i'm not beating my chest at them
so
balance of risk i was more concerned
about not
getting it than i was about getting it
so i got it
and i'm not saying that's any moral
accomplishment on my part it was just
seemed like the
tired of the lockdown and so tired of
worrying about it
not that i was worrying about getting
kovid that much but
you know it gives me some moral
authority when i say enough of this as
well
you know with these rules that have been
applied to us
curtailing our civil liberties like i
had the goddamn vaccine so get out of my
face
and maybe that's the fundamental
profession
all right thank you for listening
assuming you're still listening
see you at the next q a